okay so hold on to your hats we're going
to test out all
of the cases here comes case 1.
now remember i've got this domain here x
is less than 0
for this domain over here but it's in
our interest to select a particular
value within those domains
that's easy for me to substitute right
so in this domain i'm going to choose
x equals negative 3. i'll just say
consider that because it's in this
domain and what i do is i take that x
value and
i need a y value that goes with it so
i'm going to substitute x equals
negative 3
into this equation here so that gives me
a third times negative 3 this is why i
chose the value because it's going to
cancel my denominator that's negative 1
minus 1 negative 1 minus 1 equals
negative 2.
so for this particular value of x and y
i get z equals
minus 3 minus 2 i
so to test this what i have to do is go
back to the original equation and i'm
going to use this a fair bit so i might
as well
duplicate this down below so we'll tuck
it in this
corner over here
that'll do i can still see that all
right so i'm going to try the left hand
side first
and then i will test the right hand side
and see if i get something equivalent
all right so i've got arg of
z but the z i'm testing out here is
minus 3 minus 2i so i'm going to write
r of minus 3 minus 2i
plus i okay what am i getting out of
this you can see i can
i can collect some like terms those
imaginary terms are going to combine
together so i get
minus 3 minus i now i don't know
what that angle is off the top of my
head it's not an exact
value it's where is it it's in the third
quadrant
okay but what i can do is i can have a
look at the right hand side
and i can see if i end up getting a
similar or indeed an equal argument
let's let's give it a go
i want argument of z which we said was
minus 3
minus 2 i but you can see i'm going to
be not adding i
i'm going to be subtracting 3. so that
gives me this minus
3. when i simplify the right-hand side
you can see it's the real terms that are
going to do a bit of collecting in here
so i'll get minus
6 minus 2i
now what does this mean well we need to
think about this geometrically a little
bit we did go about this
algebraic approach to try and avoid as
much geometry as we could but you can
never get away from it
because complex numbers are inherently
two-dimensional objects that exist on
the complex plane
where are these two complex numbers uh
minus three minus i and minus six minus
two i well let's just do a very very
rough
plot they're both over here in the third
quadrant
if i go one two three four five
six those are some rough markers there
that'll do and then i go minus one
minus two all right so where is minus 3
minus
i well i'm gonna position it about here
you can see
that uh let's do it this way you can see
that it lines up with -3 it lines up
with
minus i so that is the first of my
complex numbers and then i also
have minus six minus two i which i'm
positioning around here
right so you can see there's minus six
over that way
and then minus two i down the bottom
now what is the argument for each of
these right well
we're working out the angle faced from
the positive real axis and then i rotate
around if i want the principle argument
anyway
but you can see that these are not
random points right
minus 3 minus i and minus 6 minus 2i
they exist on this same interval it's
just that this one here is twice as far
away
that's because i can write minus 6 minus
2i
as 2 lots of minus 3 minus i
and because multiplying a complex number
by a real number
all it does is it changes its scale it
doesn't um
it doesn't rotate it around in any way
you've got to multiply by something
imaginary or something complex to do
that
something with an imaginary component
that's not zero because you're
multiplying through by two
you're just extending it further away
and not changing its direction so
therefore
its argument is the same as that of
minus three minus
i now again i don't know what that angle
is
i don't know what the size of that
rotation will be
but i can say that it's the same as the
left hand side so therefore
tick this case x is less than zero
which is just going back to my number
line over here this part here this part
works
so i can say at least i've made some
progress
let's go to case two so i need to test
between
uh let's see here between zero and three
this is not quite so easy because i
can't put in zero i can't put in three
which would have been nice values to
test
i've got to pick something else so let's
just go with one that should do
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
say this is between
0 and 3 i'm going to consider
x equals 1. so if x equals 1 then the y
value that goes with that
is a third minus 1. last i checked
that's
negative 2 3. so therefore the complex
number i get with this
is one minus two thirds
i alright so now i have to test this
thing out
so what's my left hand side going to be
well my left hand side is equal to
arg of my complex number one minus two
thirds i
and then i'm adding i okay
so this is arg of one
now minus two thirds i plus i
that's going to be plus a third
i okay so far so good again
just like i did before i don't know what
that angle is but i don't need to know
exactly what its value is i just need to
compare it
with the right hand side so here i've
got arg of
same complex number one minus two-thirds
i
and then i need to just reviewing i need
to subtract three so let's do that
minus three so my real components are
going to cancel a little bit
i get negative two minus two thirds i
and at this point you're like wait a
second this
this is this is a problem right this
angle this complex number here
is in the first quadrant and this
complex over here is in the third
quadrant i don't know where these
numbers are or what their angles are
their arguments are but they can't
possibly be the same because
they're in completely different
quadrants so therefore this cannot
possibly equal
the left-hand side so this is a dud
right this is how we algebraically
confirm that oh
okay um this this particular equation
here um
is what we must satisfy but numbers in
this range like x equals one you can
test any other number in this range
you'll get the same result
um they don't work right so you're gonna
have to um say that's not part of your
domain
now uh you can't just like dust your
hands off and say oh i'm finished now
i'm tired of this algebra right if you
committed to the algebraic method
you've got to go all the way through so
we've done two cases we need to do
the third case three this is for x is
greater than three
so again we are choosing a value of x
that's just going to be convenient to us
i want multiples of three because they
will just cancel with my fractions here
so i'm going to choose six if x equals 6
then y is equal to
a third of 6 which is 2 take away
2 take away 1 which is what so that's
not too bad
therefore the z that i get with that is
just 6 plus
i so let's test it out once more with
feeling the left hand side is going to
be equal to
arg of my complex number which is six
plus i and then i'm going to add
i so i'm getting the argument of
six plus two i check the right hand side
um that's going to be the argument of
again my number 6 plus i
and i'm subtracting 3. i've done it i've
tested so many times i know this off the
top of my heart
told my head so i can say 6 take away 3
is 3
plus i but i can employ the same trick
that i did
in the first question just in reverse
right this argument here
if i multiply this by a real number the
argument doesn't change so therefore the
argument of 3 plus i
is the same as the argument of 2 times 3
plus i which is indeed what you have on
the left hand
side so this is also true
so at last i can now say therefore
the cartesian equation that's what i was
after in the first place the cartesian
equation
i worked out there was this straight
line very early on but i need to work
out which part of the straight line
it was so it's going to be not just y
equals a third
x minus one but now i can supply the
domain that goes with it which is
x is less than zero or x
is greater than three because we tested
out the
in between domain this between not and
three and we found it was
a dud it didn't work right and if you
want to do this in
interval notation because you're a fan
of it um we can say
from negative infinity remember you're
not including infinite that's why it's
not a square bracket
you got to 0 not including zero either
uh the word or
it's equivalent to insert notation the
union symbol as opposed to the upside
down one the intersection
um and then i'm going from three also up
to
infinity that's the domain that it works
for
so take a deep breath what can we
conclude from this well if you have a
look at the question from the beginning
it is obviously much more efficient and
elegant to be able to know oh
this is a pair of opposing rays and i
just have to exclude the interval
between the two
relevant reference points way faster way
more elegant right
but if you don't know that if you don't
know oh this is the kind of shape that
i'm after
it can be a little it can feel like if
you're watching someone else do this can
feel like they waved a magic wand
to arrive at this solution so this is
the way you would have to go about it if
you wanted to do it
from scratch using algebra i hope that
the length of this solution convinces
you that if you
have a choice between doing it by
geometric reasoning and just
bashing out the algebra do not bash out
the algebra because it just takes such
a very long time and it is error prone
as i've demonstrated many times
um but just to satisfy you you know this
is how it comes about
you can also see why we exclude that
in the middle interval on algebraic
terms not just on
geometric terms